the moment I left high school that's
when the partying started did that
create any kind of friction between you
and your dad you're being serious that's
your first question is there any reason
why you don't talk a lot about your
mother Pat's gonna end up being a drug
dealer I don't like his friends and a
lot of times she had a valid reason did
you ever at any point struggle with any
kind of addictions it's not good when
your friends are on shrooms and he gave
me half a pill of ecstasy why is this
unicorn chasing me and my buddies like
that's a tree it's not a unicorn who
were you in high school I'm a pen pal to
my health and guidance teacher she'll
tell me here's what's going on with my
chickens what's the story between these
semi naked pictures that you have online
Chatsworth at the time produce 80% of
all the porn around the world where is
this going I decided to play ball and I
wanted to be in the arena and this comes
with it how is it being married to
somebody like you we've never had a
conflict working with each other except
for the first week we went through this
tornado is this still the focus to be
the number one channel on YouTube for
entrepreneurs are you trying to be the
number one channel on YouTube for
mobsters or bodybuilding there is a
strategy to the madness of attainment
this is gonna sound weird I see a lot of
me and you that's all I can tell you
good luck to you
[Music]
I was a very good dancer if that's what
you want to know did you ever think you
would make it
it takes sweet victory I know this slice
meant for me yeah why would you bet on
Goliath but we got met David value Kaman
gives it values could pay this is world
of entrepreneurs we can evaluate this
run homey look what I become I'm the one
[Music]
so today's guests I have a love/hate
relationship with them I think I
probably had the most arguments and
debates with today's guests I don't know
why it is it just seems like every time
we talk it leads to a lot of friction
but today I'm hoping we can have a civil
conversation together would that be and
said my guest today is the host of value
taming as well as the CEO PHP agency'
Patrick maybe Patrick thanks for making
the time to be a guest today on that
attainment it's good to be here
so look Patrick obviously a lot of
people already know quite a lot about
your background whether it's your
parents
Iran growing up military divorce all of
that stuff I want to ask some questions
that maybe we've never touched up on
before or it's new to you is that okay
with you that's fine yeah so let's start
off at the first question look I mean
I've heard a lot of rumors that you used
to dance a lot you know nightclubs
you know Danson was like a big part of
your game back in the days when you were
younger what is the story with you being
a dancer were you a dancer before
what do you mean dancer like did you
ever dance like did you ever get paid to
dance was there any kind of elements of
you dancing on nightclubs that's your
first question I mean like I said I'm
gonna ask you some questions that we've
not asked before so yes that's that's
that's my first question I was a very
good dancer if that's what you want to
know that's really a first question
though fair enough fair enough so we
look the topic of your dad comes up a
lot you're always talking about your dad
growing up I know there was some times
where you talked about your dad wasn't
in the picture you know where you were
either you went to Germany or something
like that did that create any kind of
friction between you and your dad that's
a great question I think at one point I
was a little bit resentful probably when
I was in Germany and I didn't get a
chance to see him for two you got to
realize my dad and I I mean I've never
had a bad relationship with my dad
aside from me getting out of the
military maybe for the first month or
two because he was trying to kind of get
me to be the 14 year old kid which
wouldn't work but I've never had a bad
relationship with them I was resentful
for not seeing him for two years because
I just loved his company so much but ya
know my dad and I have had a great
relationship pretty much from day one he
always used to tell me he would say you
know the reason why I'm tough on you is
because one day I want us to be best
friends for the rest of our lives and he
is my number one best friend of my life
today so I'm curious when you were
here on with your dad talking to you
about the political climate in Iran was
that conversation taking place so he
wasn't really talking much politics with
you we never talk about politics I had
no idea what was going on his method to
the madness was to not make it seem like
anything is a big deal
it was always act it's gonna be all
right it's gonna be fine it's gonna go
away he he wanted to calmed the storm
rather than add to the storm it was
almost like at this phase of your life
you don't need to spend too much time
consuming your mind with this you need
to be a kid today and grow up and learn
to be a better leader but you don't need
to know a lot about politics that was my
dad's approach to it he kept a lot of
the pressure away from us interesting
I'm curious how does your dad feel about
your life right now I mean I'm sure he's
proud you know he's said it many times
but the relationship is a different
relationship today you know I told them
a long time ago you've done your part
the first 25 years from here on it's on
me you just tell me what you want I'm
gonna I'm gonna make sure this thing's
gonna be taken care of in he's heard
that for me I don't know how many times
you talked a lot about your father but
we don't hear a lot about your mother is
there any reason why you don't talk a
lot about your mother my mom and I have
a different kind of a relationship than
my dad my mom was a warrior everything
to her was she was always worried about
bad things happening whether it was
living in Iran with war whether it was
with us Pat's gonna end up being a drug
dealer what if patterns up doing this we
I don't like his friends what if I mean
a typical mom stuff that you're worried
about where your kids are gonna do and a
lot of times she had a valid reason
because some of the people I was hanging
around with were probably not the best
people to hang around with but but she
would always say she would say you know
Pat you can do whatever you want to do
anything can do bad if you do it I may
not find out but the man upstairs is
watching everything you do that visual
really you know did a number on me
because every time I want her to do
something that was out of the ordinary
I'm like well mom's not gonna find out
dad's not gonna find that but Shh you
mean to tell me someone's watching me
yeah maybe I ought to think about not
doing this so she instilled different
kind of mindsets I will tell you this
there is no way in the world I am Who I
am today without my mom
because my mom instilled the ability to
read people you know I watch body
language with how my mom was constantly
with her worries and concerns and how my
dad was and how the relationships were I
got that part of it from her and she's a
little bit more of a nitpicker than most
people are and I would say I'm a little
bit of a nitpicker as well but yeah my
relation my mom is very different than
my relation my dad based on that what
type of relationship would you want to
have with your kids one day obviously
it's gonna be slightly a different
relationship with me and my boys and I
had with my father because they're gonna
have resources that my dad did and out
let me explain my dad's job was to give
us a better environment to go out there
and spread our wings and whatever we're
gonna do with it right that was a whole
idea about hey my mom and my dad because
my mom was more influential on us living
leaving Iran if it wasn't up to my mom
we would probably be in Iran longer my
mom's like we got to get out of here
because he's gonna serve so his his
purpose was to get us out where and then
what I'm gonna do in my life where my
purpose for my kids is they have access
to more resources so it's about what
they do with those resources and those
contacts they have a bigger upside than
their daddy you know they have a bigger
start than their daddy
but the friendship side the relationship
side the leadership side the expectation
side a lot of that's gonna be similar
since you have a daughter I know you got
two boys and you got a daughter do you
treat all your kids the same do I treat
them all the same no I don't treat my
daughter to say matter of fact last
night was a special night because my
girl and I have a very unique
relationship she loves her mommy she's
mommies she's team mommy 100% but she's
got a different connection with me you
know when her and I go to when I put her
down and she wants to get close and you
know I'm hugging her and you know we're
spending that quality time together it's
a complete different feeling that my
boys so my daughter I treated her
completely from her but I will tell you
this she's she's a professional smack
talker I mean she knows how to bring it
she knows how to poke she knows how to
instigate got it she knows how to get
what she wants I don't know what's gonna
happen with her but she's either gonna
be in return
new or she's gonna get what she wants
cuz she's got a very very very strong
personality at a young age but it's a
complete different relationship with her
than the boys if there's one thing you
do talk about I don't know what it was
on one of the interviews you said
something about reading people you spent
a lot of time talking about reading
people do you think that's something
that can be taught I think anybody can
learn how to be better in something but
there are certain things no matter how
much time you put into getting better at
it somebody else can get great at it you
know I can learn how to hit a baseball
and get pretty good at it but I am never
gonna be able to get as good at hitting
a baseball then like Ted Williams cuz
he's had their 20/20 vision and you know
the way he would see things and
everything would slow down that's you
can't do nothing about that right there
are certain things I can do to get as
good as somebody else's but never great
reading people a part of it has got to
be the light you've lived because the
more friction of a life you've lived
where there's more controversy more
heated issues more things you saw more
fights you know more challenges right
and from your eyes as a kid coming up
all of that is memory that's being
stored here and it stays right and when
it stays here later on in your life when
you see somebody that's behaving in a
certain way you say oh this reminds me
of 28 years ago when that took place in
very similar habits and it's very
similar attitude in language if that's
the case the next move he should make
should be this oh my god that's exactly
what he did got it so you go back to the
inventory you've had so to be able to
read people as a byproduct of the life
you've lived and a part of it has to do
with who you are as an individual then a
part of it is putting into practice and
studying the skill but yeah that's what
I would say Wow you've got interesting
do you think someone can be book smart
and be good at reading people or street
smart what what do you think it is to be
good at reading people it's definitely
an advantage so think about a person
that's got so so say they face against
each other street smart
faces off against book smart right
there's gonna be places where the book
smart has an advantage over the street
smart but it's like the scene from what
is that movie is it the Good Will
Hunting right where where he says how
about them apples that one scene at the
bar he meets
a book smart guy and he's quoting all
this stuff from you know books and
bragging about it to trying to get this
girl's number and then shows up Matt
Damon who's a kid from Boston friends
when Affleck and he's a street smart guy
and book smart he annihilates this guy
so if this guy there's one thing he
can't pick up
you can't teach street smart to person
if a person was raised in a very safe
peaceful environment with not a lot of
conflicts how you gonna teach them
street smart well how you gonna teach
them that that's that part is not
possible right but if you combine two
two together that's a very dangerous
combination you know Pat you regularly
talk about hard work you're always
preaching hard work you know the whole
out work out and prove out strategize
outlast do you ever wish you worked less
so you had more time to spend with your
kids and your family
I don't think so let me explain to you
why let me explain to you why selfishly
selfishly there's nothing I enjoy more
than to be around my kids selfishly
selfishly
I would like my kids to not go to school
and we get on a plane and we go travel
places and we hang out together
selfishly I'd like to you know be with
them 24/7 and hang out and go relax and
go to movies and go to parks and play
sport I selfishly I'd love to do that
right but I have to go back and think
about what is good for them what is good
for their lives you know I got 18 years
with these guys that they're gonna be
with me after 18 years are gonna live on
for their life it is selfish of me to
want to have them around me 24/7 and not
teach them the habits that my dad taught
me to be a good citizen right what is a
good habit to learn to be a good citizen
a good habit to learn to be a good
citizen is to be independent is to lead
us to respect us to improve is to love
is to have courage wisdom tolerance
understanding it's then I get bullied
and not bully people and to do that I
woke up everything when I woke up I'm
like where's dad he was already gone to
work so for ten years in my mind is when
you wake up the man's got to be gone to
work so you got to go get to work right
okay then I would see my dad would come
home and I would see him once a week on
a Friday in Iran to Friday
is us is Sunday right so he would come
home and Friday we'd wake up early he
would take us to the park after the park
would go to church after church we'd go
to Grandma's house then we'd come home
then he would have his two hours to take
a nap that we watch it have dinner
together then we'd have family time
together watch a man would go to sleep
and I look forward to that one day
together right so for me I look at these
kids and I think about okay I have all
the resources in the world today where I
can sit home and do nothing I don't have
to work at all I can sit on would be
around these guys for the rest of my
life but is that teaching them their
habit they need to also go out and win
in their lives when they're past 18 I
don't think so I think they're gonna go
back and think about how their daddy was
when they were younger to reflect on
those memories and those habits and
hopefully apply those things into their
lives one day that's interesting you're
sharing that did you ever at any point
struggle with any kind of addictions I
don't know maybe it's drugs or alcohol
or anything else grown up my struggle
wasn't with drinking my struggle was
probably with partying and women and
chasing skirts that's probably it was my
addiction I I just I just liked it a lot
and I enjoyed it like if I could do it
every day was that haunts that
excitement of somebody new you know the
eighteen-year-old kid when a girl says
there's no way in the world and you
wanted to see if you can figure out a
way to get her to like you or be
interested in you know what's the
strategy you need to use to go about it
I was in that part that face for good
six seven years from 18 to 25 I was very
committed did it work most of the time
well you know the great thing about
strategies is you can test them multiple
times you know when you test these
strategies you think they're working
then they don't then you make some
adjustments then you get better than you
but the whole thing with strategies is
it's never a hundred percent strategies
is all about increasing the percentage
it's not a hundred percent it may work
one out of ten and then you get better
it's two out of ten than three out of
ten but it's never gonna be ten out of
ten
the idea is to make your strategies
better and as long as you're making new
strategies better whether whether it's
with you know women party in business
money finance it doesn't matter
everything's about improving your
strategies so that's the philosophy that
I applied
every aspect of my life we got a lot of
single people on my team is there any
strategies you want to share with the
rest of us that worked for you so I'll
give you two strategies
here's what I'll tell you one is if
you're by yourself and you're going to a
nightclub and the other one is who you
were going to the nightclub it's very
very important what crew you go out with
okay so let's first focus on you then
we'll give the crew if it's you okay if
it's you and you're going by yourself to
a nightclub or a place that's gonna have
a lot of options there make one round
and on your one round compliment twenty
different women in areas that they put a
lot of time into so complimenting them
on what everyone's gonna say oh my gosh
you know you got such a you know I love
your body I love you but all these that
deadlines not effective got it maybe for
a certain community but not effective
for all communities and it's been tested
by the way many many times but you're
telling a compliment on hair because I
took time to fix my hair I love your
eyebrows because eyebrows you got to put
details into it hey I got to tell you
I'm big on the right amount of makeup I
can tell you did the right amount of
makeup your face you look very very good
it's gotta be things that they're
putting time into your toes flawless I
got to him until your toes are flawless
those things stick around so when you
count the second round and you're coming
back now you got one by the way you
compliment and you move on on the second
round you get a smile then when you get
the smile you say can I get you a drink
if she's by yourself you get her a drink
there's 19 other girls that are looking
at you saying nobody complimented them
on that specific area so this part it's
pretty proven this is gonna help any
single guide if you can get to do this
you'll have a good time you look forward
to going to nightclubs the other part is
if you got a crew this part would the
cruise a complete different game plan
when you have a crew I'm working for you
so for instance I'm not flirting I'm
flirting for you I'm not flirting for me
so we'd go to club and you know you
would say I say hey who the tree grows
here you like and you'd say
the girl in the green I said who else
that one over there okay all okay let me
get to work so then I'm going and my
language is very easy because my
language is gonna be hey look I gotta
tell you I'm good I got a girl but my
buddy here who's standing right over
there thinks you're hot cat bit his
tongue you know he kind of wants to get
to know you I've been telling him go but
he can't you know he's trying to face
his fears and would you mind if you and
I go together with them and if I can
make the introduction would that be okay
with you even if it's just a
conversation oh yeah okay one out of
three times it worked
mm-hmm so and I didn't get rejected
right so I go there I make the pitch I
come back I make the presentation I make
the connection then it's on you on what
you're gonna do with the words because
now it's fully on you to be able to you
know build the conversation and get him
going
but those two strategies if I tell you
if you were part of my crew you're gonna
have a good time that's all I can tell
you you had a great time and and by the
way there's a proven record of this
people I had friends from high school
who would flying to the military just to
come and spend a week with me they all
went back wanted to come back to the
military because we did this in a very
effective fashion I'm sure you made a
lot of single guys happy with that
strategy good luck to you so you know
how you often talk about Germany how was
how was that experience for you you know
when you lived at their refugee camp is
that good memories bad memories what was
it like living in Germany at the refugee
camp Germany to me is I mean I can't
wait to go back because it's it's one of
my fondest memories of my life
everything about Germany was good to me
I lived at a refugee camp and we got so
close at this refugee camp I learned so
much about human nature because we had
people there from Yugoslavia Pakistan
Afghanistan Poland Russia Czech Republic
at the time Albania and all of us were
together so imagine living in a
community together for a year and a half
and some are sent back some stay some
leaves some get citizenship some don't
you're seeing this whole hardship and
and we got very very close very close to
the point where have a relations with
some of them from the refugee camp and
that was an 89 I still have a
relationship with some of the people
till today and then you know Germany was
also part where my dad officially wasn't
around me so that's when I realized
now you don't have a father figure in
your life there was no doubt in Germany
that came straight to us so I had to
learn to man up very very quickly in
Germany and I think that was an edge
because that to learn how to make money
I had to learn how to make friends
how to learn how to fight I had to learn
how to defend myself after on how to
defend my family when our backs against
the wall you have the instinct to want
to protect your family see all the
instincts are in here it's pulling those
instincts out and sometimes to pull out
the right instincts require some
travesty or crisis or challenges to go
through and when you don't have a father
that's around you and your parents don't
have money you got to figure out a way
to go out to make the money if Germany
doesn't happen I don't know if I have
the experience and the toughness that I
have to do it because of living at that
camp for two years
really but memories incredible memories
so look you know every guest on guy to
me that's been interviewed wonder kind
of question is who were you in high
school so having said that who were you
in high school who was I in high school
that's a good see it's a good question
who was I in high school so in high
school I was actually not that I never
had a girlfriend in high school by the
way it's one thing most people don't
know I never had a girlfriend I wasn't
the the ladies man in high school that
came military not in high school so in
high school I was probably the guy that
hung out and got along with everybody I
got along with the gangsters I got along
with the kids that were regular middle I
got along with athletes I got along with
the cool guys I got along with the Nerds
I got along with the teachers for the
most part my outside of Miss Rose who
gave me a D in ceramics and made no
sense to me when she gave me a B in
ceramics but I got along almost with
everybody
until today I'm at one of my pen pals I
write a letter I'm a pen pal to my help
and guidance teacher till today miss
Sinclair her and I write letters to each
other I mean she's the reason why I
joined the army 14 years old on 41 was
27 years ago and we write letters she'll
tell me here's what's going on with my
chickens cuz she's got chickens you know
she's got she loves animals and she's
got all the stuff that we go back and
forth but I speak to my math teacher mr.
woods and he'll send Armenian mess
just to me because he's a white guy that
tries to speak Armenian but in high
school I was a guy that lifted weights I
was a guy that had a good physique I was
a guy that worked out I was a guy that
was obsessed with wanting to be in the
straw' Olympia I was that guy in high
school didn't play organized sports
wasn't a big GPA you guys at one point a
GPA guy and every time I went to school
I would sell something and after high
school I was working at haagen-dazs so
if it wasn't money or working or
weightlifting or bodybuilding there
wasn't a lot of my life at that time let
me ask you did you consider yourself a
pretty confident high school student I
think if you asked my friends if I was
confident they they'll probably tell you
there is an element of confidence and
there's an element of worry you know an
element of I don't know if I'm going to
make it out of this or not and I don't
know what the future holds but at the
same time one thing everybody will say
is I was always a dreamer hmm always
everything was about hey you know what
do you want to do one day in your life
you got four options which one would you
rather choose being a billionaire being
a best basketball player in the world
being a best performer in the world or
being a best actor in the world who
would you want to be and we'd have this
conversation imagine if one day this
happens to you what would you do so the
dreaming component was always there the
confident was always there I was always
concerned about my mom my sister who's
my sister gonna be dating my dad's
health
those were my concerns at the time
because the three people that mattered
the most to me at that point in my life
was my mom my sister my dad those three
I thought about them a lot and then it
was everything else so I know he said
earlier you never really had any kind of
addictions as a as a kid you know up to
18 in high school never know did you
ever have any experiences with drugs at
an adult I did and I'll tell you each
time when I did so one time I think we
were at the Mayan and my buddies I'm you
know I'm combining alcohol and I'm
combining beer and everything together
and it's after the army and one of my
buddies says here to throw this ecstasy
and he gave me half a pill of ecstasy I
have no idea what kinda was but he gave
me half
of ecstasy and he gave it to me and I
took it and it had the worst reaction
for me we went to this jack-in-the-box
right across the street from Conrad's in
Glendale and we parked the car from the
tree
the tree looked like a unicorn chasing
me I mean it's like completely don't
found it saying why is this unicorn
chasing me and my buddies like that's a
tree it's not a unicorn so it had a
complete different reaction for me and
it's not good when your friends are on
shrooms and and they're trying
everything and you're trying to kind of
hold it together so I don't even know if
it was a unicorn or what it was but I
can take from that day I said don't ever
you know give me any kind of ecstasy and
what's so funny is one of my year of
very good friends was a guy that was one
of the biggest dealers of ecstasy in
America he's sold probably hundred
thousand at a time and he was very good
at what he did one of the biggest
partiers out there and then I I smoked
pot well if I smoked pot it was a few
times where the girl I was with is when
I smoked pot and the experience would
pod was complete opposite it was a very
very different experience it just slowed
me down that I don't want to slow down
but it was something that made me think
less and I know some people get panicky
and they start having to a paranoia when
they're smoking weed complete opposite
effect on me but that was 21 22 23 years
old and then I used to be a bodyguard
for two or three weeks for one of the
biggest dealers in LA for cocaine so a
couple times he said you got to see the
product I got I tried that I said it's
the worst drug for me because I'm
already here you want me to do this I'm
gonna go here not gonna happen
but outside of that nothing else you
know though that was my experience so
out of those three I can tell you the
only one that may have a positive effect
on me
is probably we've all the other ones no
effect no positive effect definitely no
positive effect definitely a negative
effect so that that's kind of what my
how my body reacts to it let me let me
ask you have you ever experienced
anybody like a friend or family losing
the battle of addiction to any drugs
yourself when I speak on stage I've
gotten emotional four times
when I speak on stage four times I've
got emotional to the point where I can't
control myself and I don't know like it
really has gotten the best of me I think
Mario is probably witnessed three of
them when he sees seeing this happen and
out of the four times that this has
happened where it's been absolute losing
control of emotions three of them is
because of a friend Arman Arman was a
very good friend
Arman was a very talented guy I love the
guy I loved him till - I think about him
till today he was a funny guy he was a
prank guy he was a brilliant guy he was
a you know fungi to be around business
guy you know he wanted to make money he
wanted to do something he wanted to make
his parents proud and at the same time
he was chippy you like breaking the
rules and he got caught up on vicodin
and vicodin got the best of him I took
him to multiple different places to
rehabilitation centers and we went all
over the place but when that day
happened when I got the call I I
couldn't tell you it's probably May 5th
or five and that one really was a tough
one so yeah I have lost friends to it
and that's one of them I have a handful
of stories like that
another one is a recent one that
happened that was over cocaine and it
was one of my very good friends who
happen to also be one of our leaders in
the company who got caught up and that
is one that was painful I went to Miami
to the funeral but I have a handful of
those stories that are painful but yes
I've seen it happen and it's not fun
especially when it's a friend and a
family member that that happens - that's
unbelievable Wow
let me ask you how did you go about
joining the armies there's story behind
it so when I got out of high school I
went to one semester of Glendale
Community College and then I went to the
army a week after my mom went back to
Iran she said you have a couple choices
you can come back to Iran with me or go
stay here I said I'm gonna stay here I
went to my sister I said let me live
with you for a month she said no problem
I gave her my computer and paid her rent
money one day I woke up after partying
till four o'clock in the morning my
friends downstairs at the sauna and we
were drinking heavily I'm 18 years old
at this time and this is when I started
partying right the moment I left high
school that's when the partying started
and you know that day for me when that
happened I woke up in the morning I went
downstairs to my car my mom left me a
Toyota Corolla 1983 and the car wasn't
there
so I called the cops I'm like the car's
not here is it stolen six months later
they contact me telling me the car was
in Rosarita so somebody stole the car
went straight to Mexico with the car but
then when they stole the car I got a
hangover I don't feel like going to
Glendale Community College Oh going to
my job at Burger King that call my dad I
said dad take me to the recruiting
station in Glendale we went to Glendale
my recruiter was hey soos Guerra
I said hey soos if you can't get me to
go to the army tomorrow I'll sign up
right now he said I can't get you
tomorrow he says can take 90 days I'm
not signing together of his 90 days two
weeks later I was in South Carolina and
I went to the army it's the story so
when it comes out to your peers if we
were to talk to any of your peers from
the Army what identity did you have who
were you amongst your peers I was the
leader of the group that that part is is
a deaf definite it didn't matter if you
were a sergeant or not I was the leader
of the group if we went to the club if
we went to the gym if a fight was to
break out if something were to happen I
think they would say I was the leader of
the group and I'm in contact with most
of them so if you were to talk to them
they'd probably tell you that as well so
if we were going to a club we're gonna
go to the club that I had a mind that we
wanted to go to and it was typically a
good move when I chose the club because
we're gonna have a good time when we'll
go to the club you know typically for
people who are in the military they all
have a lot of crazy stories what were
some of your craziest story of being in
the army
there's a lot of them that I don't want
to share but I'll give you one of them I
mean my buddy had a truck an f-150 truck
you know we wanted to get six guys with
us to go to Panama City now you got to
realize the drive is a nine hour drive
and you can only fit three people in the
cabin and we have clothes to take with
us because a weekend in the military is
called the Danza dances a four-day
weekend they call it the dance everybody
wanted a dancer so we get in the truck
I'm sitting in the truck and my friend
and then Jeff was driving the truck
Bradford but there was three guys laying
in the back no padding nothing but
because you wanted to go to Panama City
to go to club level on Spinnaker's you
were willing to make the sacrifice and
the best part about these trucks was
when we were driving and there were
bumps because when there is bumps these
guys are you know did they're flying
high and it was probably not safe they
to debate in the military you're not
thinking a lot and then one time we're
going we went through this tornado and
rain which was great because all our
clothes got wet so by the time we got to
Panama City everyone's clothes as wet
all of it and the guys in the back are
sitting in a puddle for four five hours
go 70 miles an hour and you know
fortunately nothing happened obviously I
don't advise that for for anybody
although I know a lot of people will a
few in the military but that's one of
the stories but in a military you're
you're not thinking a lot it's just
constantly trying to push the envelope
in another thing and it's everything's a
dare I dare you to do it I thought you
were tough I thought you had it in you I
thought you called yourself a party guy
what was this all about
I am then if you are get in the back of
the truck let's go it was it's
constantly trying to challenge you and
you know if you didn't take the
challenge then you're gonna be for a
whole week called out for being a pansy
for not wanting to take up the challenge
so you're either gonna take the
challenge and if you don't you're gonna
hear it from everybody for weeks you
almost have to say no I'll get in the
back of the truck I'll take one for the
team but that's that's one of the crazy
stories we have you know this one may be
a curveball for you but I just have to
ask because it comes up after you post
pictures right on Instagram any of you
post a picture about you know some
videos some cut from there some and in
all of a sudden there's pictures of
someone semi half-naked pictures of you
what what era of your life was this and
what's the story between these semi
naked pictures that you have online what
do you mean nothing's on social media
these are pictures I took years ago but
some of them maybe I'm posing yes
there's probably gonna be some of them
that I'm posing because back in 1999 I
think I did a photo shoot March of 2000
at Marina del Rey okay and some of the
photo shoots was being done because of a
direction I was going to my life with
entertainment and we took those photos
but that was a long time ago matter if I
gotta take a funny story one time I had
a picture in my closet or something like
that and I asked one of my co-workers to
go to my room and grab something and
they accidentally saw some of the
pictures
oxidation and never seen the pictures it
was sitting there and let's just say the
reactions were pretty excited shout a
video to record the reaction this person
had but there's some crazy pictures out
there but I have them the world should
have me and my photographer albums so
what was your transition from leaving
the military to going into cells because
you know those are complete two
different worlds where did the sales
component come in so when I got out of
the military I needed a job so I called
my sister I said I need a job and she
got me a Java Bali Total Fitness got me
an interview with Lunetta and Ophelia
and Donnell these three guys interviewed
me I got hired I went to the training
program came back they placed me at
Culver City working with Cisco and
that's when I got into sales it was a
slow start the first month but then
Cisco was patient with me giving me the
right direction I was working with a
good team with Dexter Molina Rimmer you
know Joe
Silvio we had a great squad of guys to
work with and a big influence of my
sales career started from Culver City
Bally's why don't people like sales by
the what do you think people don't like
sales if you're selling a product you
don't believe in you're probably not
gonna like sales but if you're selling a
product you believe in I guarantee it's
gonna be a different way your look at
sales because you believe in the product
so think about whatever your favorite
car is whatever your favorite brand is
closes and you've never sold before if a
person wants to go in sales just make a
list of what products you like then you
want to get into self go sell that you
know or uh you know find somebody that
you're working with so one is the
product the other one is finding
somebody you work with because sometimes
sales managers some of them are bad and
if you work for bad sales manager who
doesn't know how to get the best daddy
and work you and challenge you and push
you sometimes you're not gonna do good
so it's either find products that you
fully believe in to sell or it's find
sales leaders that you can work closely
with that can bring out the best in you
and challenge you find those two it's
gonna end up working out for you you
mean you mean everything a lot for sales
everything in life is sales yes
everything is so it doesn't matter if
it's relationship parenting business
wanting a promotion your girl your boy
your husband your wife your parents you
know every aspect of the life is all
selling and if you show me anybody
that's being left behind and a family in
a job for a promotion and anything
that's
money that doesn't know how to sell sell
themselves if you learn how to sell
yourself and you deliver you're probably
gonna have a better life than somebody
that does know how to sell themselves
and they deliver but you gotta learn how
to sell yourself he gives you an upper
advantage a you know an unfair advantage
in a marketplace when you're not a
communicator message and deliver to
people can you talk about your first
sale what was alike when I was at Cobra
City Mall and I'm walking around trying
to sell memberships and then she walks
up and we start talking she was so nice
to me young attractive girl
we started talking she bought the
membership I called sequester's Cisco I
just sold my first membership and I
couldn't believe she said yes
seventy-five dollars down thirty two
dollars a month at the time and that was
the beginning of many more sales to be
made you ended up going to one of the
worst locations in Bally's that wasn't
performing that well and then you turn
it into one of the best performance gyms
what happened there yes I got a call
from Robby Solomon saying you ought to
go work at Chatsworth Bally's now
Chatsworth if you don't know where
Chatsworth is Chatsworth at the time
produce 80% of all the porn around the
world so most of our customers were porn
stars now if you were a chance Ford
number I'm not telling you were porn
star but I'm telling you most of our
customers were porn stars so if you work
there it was it was you had to learn how
to communicate with the community
because every market is how you talk to
the community as selling memberships in
Hollywood on L central was very
different than selling memberships in
Oxnard Bally's when it opened up versus
the Bally's you sold in Culver City then
the one in Chatsworth you can't speak
the same language to the customers
they're the demographic is different so
you got to learn to adjust and speak
their language but when I went there the
club was hitting 42% when I left it was
a hundred and twenty five percent of the
goals every single month because we
worked on a script we worked on the
language we worked on the culture we
walked around the club we said hello to
our guests we shook hands with the
guests we spotted the guest can I help
you with this and that created an
environment where guests wanted to give
us referrals they would bring people in
hey my buddy also wants to be a member
he I was telling him about you hey my
girlfriend wants to come my mom and dad
are here and everybody started showing
up because people were glad to be part
of a gym that was incredible right
across the street was a powerhouse gym
and
that chatsworth for that period was
dominating the leaders bulletin so for
somebody that works as hard as you do
you're always you know working with your
farm the stories Instagram you're at the
office you're doing stuff how is it
being married to somebody like you
what's it like to be married to me so
I'm you're gonna know I'm gonna work
you're gonna know I'm a building if I'm
not at the office if I'm on the road if
I'm traveling if I'm in meetings I'm
growing the business you will know that
part and then when it's time with family
I enjoy my sundays and sundays exclusive
for my kids my wife or my family I look
forward to Sundays and we're gonna have
our date nights on Saturday nights
you're gonna see somebody that's gonna
be working and you're also gonna see
something like the other day my son will
come here almost spend some time
together he'll run around and have fun
they're always at the office they enjoy
being him and we got slides here we got
video games here we got ping pong here
we set up the gym in a way where kids
also want to be here right so they're
coming here regularly and when they come
they can figure out a way to entertain
entertain themselves on the better
things about being a business owner
entrepreneurs you get to dictate what
kind of an environment you want to
create where it's either family friendly
or not I decided to create a type of an
environment that my kids also gonna
enjoy coming here so yes I am still
working very hard if not harder today
you don't typically hear you know
traditional thought isn't husband and
wife work together right I know you and
your wife work together she's in your
company with you regularly how is that
dynamic of the two of you working
together on a daily basis work
we never have issues when it comes to
work because everybody knows their role
she's empowered she's a VP of Operations
and she does a very good job as VP of
Operations I'm very proud of our efforts
and then I'm the CEO so at work I'm not
a husband at work on the CEO at work
she's a VP of operations so if you asked
her she would tell you we've never had a
conflict working with each other
except for the first week when we tried
to share an office together and I'm on
the phones for nine hours if you can't
handle me being on the phones for nine
hours you need your own office so we got
our own office but outside of that our
challenges are not work-related it's
more we'll argue with off work personal
life just like any other relationship
family feud challenges kids but we have
zero issues when we work together you
know it's interesting you say that I sat
down with mark demos
who he was from Seattle and one of the
things he was doing is he was working
with a lot of these families from Amazon
and Microsoft and the template and
family and these billionaires and he
would talk about what it was like to be
the kids of a billionaire do you ever
feel like you ever in your back of your
mind do you think about like maybe
you're casting a shadow over your kids
and it's gonna be tough for them to want
to overcome that does that ever cross
your mind what about testing a shadow my
kids know I don't worry about that at
all although I don't know what it is for
them so I have to respect the fact that
they may feel that way but I'm not the
one that's gonna be telling them you
better become an entrepreneur because
your daddy was an entrepreneur or this
is a legacy business one day you're
gonna run it
there is no plans of that they have to
tell me that they want to do that it's
got to be their choice because if it's
their choice they're gonna give their
best if it's my choice during the choice
they're not gonna give their best so
shadow to me is when somebody at the top
is forcing you to do what they want you
to do there is no desire here making my
kids do whatever they want to do now is
there gonna be an element of can I ever
reach the level that my dad reached in
his life because in life there's nothing
more annoying than a great example
nothing when you got a grip my dad
worked so hard so it was always annoying
to try to get in a shadow of hard work
because it was like Scott works so hard
man he always says whatever he says he's
gonna do he does it man I feel like I
have to meet that but it worked here
because I wanted to duplicate his
example so but I do know there's gonna
be some of it and how they process
that's gonna be on them but they're
never gonna get pressure from Daddy to
try to be daddy they're gonna get my
year's support to want to encourage them
to pursue their dreams and it happens to
be us work obviously ideally I'd love
for us to run a business together but I
can make that happen they got to make
that decision to happen for folks who
consume your content it's constant you
got to go forward you got to work hard
you got to stay focused you got to do
this you know sometimes maybe for the
audience it's kind of all my gosh do I
have to be on all the time is it ever
draining to be Patrick mad David no
never not at all
like when I tell you not at all I mean
literally not at all because at me
because you have to realize well you
know when my wife and I made a decision
to become entrepreneurs we started a
company and then four weeks later we get
a massive lawsuit from a horrible
in our company and when they were in bed
and you know we're talking hey so was it
the right decision all they said this
was like six months into the business
and all my savings is depleting I'm all
the way down to $13,000 she doesn't know
it but I know it 12:30 months into the
business you know and it's like oh my
gosh you know look at the work all this
other stuff what are we gonna do so look
this is what we signed up for if it's
what you signed up for what do you mean
draining you chose this life this is not
a dictatorship worse I was forced to
live this life I chose to live this life
if I chose to live this life it is on me
to make it work so draining to me is if
you were forced to do something that you
never wanted to do in the first place
but if you chose to it's on you to have
a positive attitude to go make your work
not on anybody else and I was never
forced to I chose to do this and I'm
glad I did and we did our best to make
it work maybe let me rephrase this so it
can it can help out a little bit more is
it tiring to always be on
oh I'm not always on no I mean listen
the cameras are not always on me I'm not
always on there's days that you know I
get upset or I'm frustrated at times but
maybe something didn't go my way or deal
fell through or you know someone's
trying to do whatever they're doing
defamation of character deals all this
other stuff you have to realize when a
person decides to plate it in the arena
take any of these athletes if you don't
like doing postgame interviews you
signed up for this you have to do the
postgame interviews you have to do the
media work it's part of the work so then
don't go toy for the MB or MLB you
decided to do this it's your choice I
decided to play ball and I wanted to be
in the arena and this comes with it so
is it tiring sometimes yes are you
sometimes gonna feel like oh my god we
gave our best and we got to recover
absolutely you know are there days where
you're not having the best of days yes
is there an element of being a human
100% but is it still exciting to get up
the next thing starts your day I can't
even tell you how exciting it is I've
probably not been this excited about
start my days in my entire life as I am
today and it's not getting less it's
getting more exciting and let me explain
why so it's not like one of these
one-liners you say just to kind of say
it here's why there are more unknowns in
my
life today than ever before the more
unknowns you have positive on those not
negative on those a negative unknown is
what pending lawsuit is something you
messed up with and it spinning like you
don't know what's gonna happen those
negative pending unknowns they are
draining create anxiety panic a lot of
that stuff but when he got positive
unknowns I don't know what my sons are
gonna do so exciting I don't know my
daughter's gonna be oh my gosh I don't
what's gonna happen with this business
here we're growing that's exciting I
don't know what direction the media
company is going
that's exciting there are so many
positive unknowns - babe that's like a
gas tank just fueling you up throughout
the entire day that's what's that that's
what it feels like today with my life
the one episode you did I think it's
titled 14 strategies to be glides right
and this guy there's an enemy it's like
hell what if you're facing somebody
that's bigger than you who are your
current enemies that you're going up
against who is my biggest enemy as I
came up competing as I came up in the
marketplace there was always a target
you know I'm going after this guy who
I'm going after this company I'm going
after this person nothing creates more
urgency for me than knowing and wanting
to find out what my capacity looks like
so for example imagine if if I give my
best I can get to here
right I want to meet this guy I can't
live my life getting to here so the
enemy is this guy slow me down to just
celebrate what I currently have today
but I'm not interested in meeting this
guy I'm interested in meeting this guy I
want to meet this guy I want to know
what this guy's capable of doing I want
to know how this guy thinks I want to
know how this get processes issues I
want to know how he looks at challenges
or you know in every aspect of like how
to process politics parenting marriage
kids finance economy religion sports how
do you process all of that how do you I
want to talk to this guy I want to meet
this guy so the enemy is anything and
any spirit that prevents me from meeting
this guy that's the person I want to
meet if even I did in my way
of meeting this guy I'm gonna make sure
I straighten that up because I don't
even want myself my victories my current
whatever accolades that I have to make
me feel like oh my gosh you've already
reached it look at the life you're
living
no I enjoy being in the arena there is
nothing more exciting than being in the
arena then the idea is which is what I'm
doing then it's on the arena then it's
to build many arenas then to see how big
you can scale it stir the phases of life
you're going to write so I'm excited
about always the next phase I would
assume in the world of business you know
for someone that's in it you know no
businessman or businesswoman that's
undefeated but you're gonna lose every
once in a while I wonder how do you
handle the feat or loss I will tell you
like for me when something happens
that's a setback or a defeat I like to
immediately get back into it again like
you know yeah they'll give you a perfect
example the other day I experienced the
loss right and it was 9 o'clock at night
10 o'clock at night on a Saturday night
right I didn't like it what I do I came
straight to the office and I was used to
2:30 in the morning and I woke up Sunday
at 7:30 I still have my day with my kids
and all day I didn't take a nap not that
I was with them but I chose to come here
to the office why I come here to the
office to map out my next modes so took
to me a defeat is got to have an element
of getting back into the ring ASAP I
remember one time my son there was an
incident the pool with our kids where he
fell in the pool and his sister fell in
the pool and he panicked for his sister
we got the sister out but he panicked
for his sister and from that moment on
he went in the house and my wife comes
dude the guy doesn't wanna go in to pull
up so it's not gonna happen he's got to
go in to point he's not going in the
pool as he's gonna go in the pool he
says baby I'm telling he's not going to
pull he doesn't want to go outside to be
by do and I know this kid loves to swim
I came and I said let's go so I'm not
going this is hug me no let's go so I'm
not going so they make a promise to you
I will not ask you or drop you in the
pool by yourself I'm not gonna do that
if you do this because you chose to do
it but hug me as hard as you want so he
hugged me so let's get crying the entire
time we go in the pool
I'll in the pool he's hugging me and I
said look at me look at me look at me
he's
don't panic it's just a pool you know
how to do this nothing happens your
sister you're okay
you'd like swimming I don't like
swimming you love swimming I see how you
swim I can't get you out of the polar
ice cream to bring you up so it's really
minded him and processing everything
with them and it needs to look at me
acid now I want you to go from hugging
me in the front to hug me in the back
she hugs me in the back okay now I'm
gonna go underwater we're gonna go
together and then we go in the water we
come up now I want you to come to the
front I said I want you to hold my hands
I'm not gonna let go just hold my hands
and kick
he's kicking he's kicking took me an
hour and a half I'm doing this with them
an hour and a half later I let go my
hands he swam but I'm right there he
came we did this a few times and then
his brother came in and then he forgot
about it and then he swam the rest of
the day but in that moment if we don't
face that defeat that could affect him
for next 5 10 15 20 years it could
affect him as a 24 year old why would I
do that to him no when you have a loss
or a defeat you got to get back into the
ring immediately when I have them I'm
going straight to my ring because I get
got to get back into her get hit again
to face it or else to fear and
imagination creates this bigger monster
inside and it stays in you and grows I
don't want that you don't want that so
you got to face it immediately when it
happens to us that's what I do you've
referenced this concept of David vs
Goliath
again that episode I talked about
earlier you did which is 14 strategies
on how to beat Goliath so it was like
this David Glide David Glide maybe at
the beginning stages you were a David
but some may look at you as a kalaiy
today who do you relate to more David or
Goliath to some of the people that I
went up against I may be right now to
them yes but I don't see myself as
Goliath I think Goliath was arrogant you
know the reference to the story is
arrogant cocky and didn't see anybody as
a threat and he thought he was
untouchable
and David to me was more strategic he
looked at the other person's strengths
and figure out a way to have an edge
over the other person I mean it's
constantly being David yeah I'm sure
there's other David's that see me as
acolyte that they want to come after us
I want to compete with us more power to
my incursion to do that but I relate
more to David than I do to Goliath
you've quoted Robert Greene from 33
strategies of war you
about Sun Tzu Art of War you know and
there's a lot of different strategies
and techniques of doing certain things
but do you feel you you're open to or
you have shared all your strategies with
everybody or they some that we don't
know about not all of them you know I
mean obviously you know you're you're
sharing what you're sharing what you're
doing it's great
yes but few them will be when I'm you
know putting an event together at the
vault or something like that where it's
intimate and it's close and the smaller
setting your biggest strategies are
always going to be unveiled in smaller
settings not bigger settings so if you
are in a smaller setting of course every
single one of the guys that I work with
who are in a group of five or two or
three anything because we're on the same
team together but if it's a bigger scale
with everybody not all of it
smaller scale all of it so look you
often get criticized for you know
context you followed the content in the
comment section why is he giving away
all this content in other you know
online gurus they're selling this
content for a couple thousand dollars
but he gives you a there's got to be
bigger motivation is there a scheme is
there something you're doing with your
you know intentions are giving away this
content for free I think scheme is a
negative word I don't know if I'm
comfortable with the word scheme if
you're saying strategy I can say yes of
course there is I mean absolutely there
is there is a strategy to the madness of
attainment but here's what it is gonna
happen scheme to me is I win you lose
strategy to me is I win you win we're
both winning together so there's a very
big long-term strategy with vitamins I
wish there was a value team when I was
coming up because I wanted to go to a
place where I can get this content I
didn't have to get a little book so
YouTube has given us the opportunity to
create content where somebody can watch
this kind of stuff so one is I created a
platform that I wanted when I was coming
up it's always my mindsets always that
remember how earlier I said if I believe
in a product I can sell it I look at
what's missing and what I wish I had and
then I go build it so that's value tame
it and I believe people learn better if
there's an aspect of entertainment to it
right not just an aspect of value value
by itself us-born so value with
entertainment becomes
value taemin right the great thing about
online gurus is you can go out and
create content and if your message
resonates with people you know more
power to them okay
I like folks who have built a business
before and we will touch topics on value
taming that people think about but they
don't want to talk about it I mean
sometimes we'll cross the line with
politics there's a lot of people that
are frightened of talking about politics
you know what if they lose an audience
what if somebody says something what if
somebody disagrees with them right but
at the same time I'm speaking and
creating content on topics that people
are thinking about and I'm trying to
give a different perspective so whatever
these online gurus want to do if they're
solving for selling more courses if
they're solving for selling more
products and that's their main outcome
yes I understand their strategy but
that's not our outcome obviously there's
a vision there's a long term goal and
what we want to do and this is just one
aspect of what our long term goal is
with media that we're trying to do and
so that's why I create content the way I
do the topic of trust is always being
talked about on value taming you're
regularly talking about who to trust
levels of trust you know seven ways to
know if you can trust somebody or not do
you feel like you're someone that's easy
for you to trust other people or is it
tougher for you to trust folks you know
it's kind of like being 18 years old and
you go to apply for the first credit
card right you what's your credit score
when you're 18 years old and you've
never used your credit your credit is
typically 720 because the the FICO
formula is give everybody the best got
it give them the benefit of the doubt
you all start with a 720 not an 820 but
at least a 720 and then from there the
credit bureau determines whether you
drop off you didn't make your car
payment you don't make your credit card
payment on time and your credit score
goes from a 720 to a 680 to 622 580 now
everybody knows you're not disciplined
and now banks not gonna give you a
million dollar loan or half a million
dollar loan or $100,000 car loan because
everyone knows your credibility score
now right or you get your 720 you get a
car you make the payment on time good
you got a second car you make the
payment on time now you're 740 you
bought a house for 3 years you made the
payment on time now your credit score
778 now we know who you are but we
started you at 720 very similar formula
everybody who works there
a certain level of score that they've
given the benefit of the doubt and at
that point either you build on it
or you take points away that's pretty
much exactly how I run it when I'm
working with folks on my team you know
when I watch your content on YouTube in
and if I follow you on Instagram I see
you posting stuff pranks you know you
got the one your editor singing you got
Mario you're doing stuff you got you
know there's there's almost like a fun
side so I wonder what is your tactic for
handling pressure especially the fact
that you're running the business the
family the kids the investors all this
stuff how do you manage the pressure in
your life you know honestly how I handle
pressure is humor and pranks if you are
not allowed listen just watch Jordan if
you watch Jordan you would have seen
that one of the great things about him
was behind closed doors the guy was
about pranks it was about fun it was
about jokes it was about a laughter any
kind of pressure type situation you have
to relieve it by having a lot of humor
and funny things that happen if you
don't you can't man
military when you're sitting around and
you don't have a lot of things to look
forward to this is when you hear a joke
this is when you hear a laughter this is
when people are telling each other
stories funny stories because laughter
and pranks and humor tends to bring
pressure down you need humor humor is a
big part of pressure you're on the other
side meaning you create the content and
and you know millions of people watch it
and consume it and whether you motivate
them I know you don't like to be called
a motivational but you do you sometimes
motivate people you inspire them or you
give them strategies but who's
motivating the motivator where do you
get to get your content to be motivated
you got to figure out a way to have
something feed you because if you're not
feed being fed you're gonna be empty
doesn't matter how much of a peak
performer you are you got to find a
source of you being fed bokes
relationship mentors advisors counsel
for somebody to give you encouragement
you need to be able to do that because
if you don't then eventually gonna be
training yourself this is why you hear
even a high-performing athlete goes and
pays $400,000 a year to have somebody
mentally and emotionally keep him stable
there's a reason for doing that this is
a guy that's made it to the highest
level why does he need somebody of
course he needs somebody just because
you made it to the high school but
doesn't mean you don't also need to have
somebody motivate you or work with you
or give you clarity so yes I'm a big
believer of having somebody that's
driving you as well you
mentioned many times different people
that have influenced you a lot in your
lives but if we were just to kind of get
it out there in the open so we can all
find out who would you say are some of
the folks that influenced you the most
in your life these guys in the back the
paintings
whether it's MLK Milton Friedman Shaw
Sena Tupac Lincoln JFK Einstein they
influenced me tremendously and a lot of
the faces that you've seen here these
three different personalities an element
of each within me whether it's the Hulk
Batman or the Joker or Jordan Colby
Brady Tyson anybody that goes above and
beyond influences me their method of
madness to how they wanted to compete
when they went up against their opponent
I relate to a lot you tell the story
about how you started the channel first
it was called Patrick Greg David right
and was like two minutes with Pat
motivational videos and then you go and
change channels into value Tim and start
doing entrepreneurship and pretty much
the channel becomes a normal Channel on
YouTube for entrepreneurs but then you
know you've been doing a lot of
bodybuilding interviews and a lot of you
know mobsters and mafias you know is
this still the focus to be the number
one channel on YouTube for entrepreneurs
are you trying to be the number one
channel on YouTube for mobsters or
bodybuilding what words where is this
going
of course it's the channel for
entrepreneurs it just so happens we've
been interviewing a lot of mobsters so
value to me right now has probably four
audiences one is the folks in a fitness
world bodybuilders another one is those
who enjoy the mob stories whether it's
you know Sammy the bull Gravano or Frank
Cullotta or Oscar Goodman or Michael
Franzese or whoever else maybe and then
you have folks who are in the
entrepreneurs space and then some that
are into politics but it's it's really
for it's so funny because I'll run into
people at the airport or at different
places and they'll say I follow value
taemin because of the entrepreneur
content I follow all the mob interviews
I follow all the bodybuilding and
everything I follow so there's different
audiences for it originally it was
one-dimensional II was just entrepreneur
today we've been able to do more that
part wasn't intentional it's just levels
of interestings that I know about that
draws the audience and maybe it's the
questions that are being asked that's
leading them to want to know
more about the guests that we're having
the guess you've had they're from
different walks of life whether it's I
think you sat down with general Spalding
I think he was an Air Force general and
he had some insider information to share
with us on China and the relationship
with us or Kevin Hart or even Sammy the
bull Gravano where he sat down and did
the interview with you and you opened up
or even Kobe Bryant you were one of the
last ones to interview Kobe Bryant what
do you take away from all of these
stories when you sit down and talk to
them I mean obviously it's a different
perspective for the viewer but how are
you processing all these guests that
you're sitting down with it's hearing
their story and seeing similarities
between what led them to become who they
are like what I'm looking for is to see
what made a Sammy become Sammy and what
made a Kevin Hart become Kevin Hart what
made general Spaulding have the opinion
that he has on China I'm curious about
that when he lived in China for three
years what did he learn about China and
obviously Kobe Bryant is a guy that I
followed from the day he came into the
NBA when he got traded for Vlade Divac
I'm a die-hard Lakers fan so at that
time when we got him it was just a
beautiful thing because him and Shaq
running together was a beautiful thing
that's one that we will appreciate for
the rest of our lives because not only
did I grow up with Kobe Kobe and I are
six weeks apart and we were establishing
a relationship together as a guy that
he's a competitor and him and I that
some of the conversations we had
off-camera were 10 times better than the
conversations we had in the interview
mm-hmm so that's that's one that my wife
and my kids still talk about regularly
you know when it's with Kobe but the
main thing is what got the person to
become who they are today and if there
was a tweak that was made in that moment
could they have gone in a different
direction we would have known their
stories either for positive or a good
could there been an opportunity for us
to prevent a Sammy from becoming from
happening could could an inspiration or
somebody given him better direction had
Sammy go completely different route so
every one of them has a different story
but you're trying to find out well let
what caused them to become the way they
are today value teaming to me is a lot
of your philosophies being shared with
the rest of the world right so it's
kinda like you believe this or you
believe that but there's a lot of
different
once do you have a core philosophy or
core philosophies that you live by like
one yeah I don't know if I have one I
think I have many now obviously whatever
I teach my kids lead respect and prove
love but I think within that is a lot of
my philosophies if I were to put the
biggest one in there you know I would
say rule of threes is big for me
anything you do three times you know how
to do if you've been able to make
$100,000 three years in a row you know
how to make a hundred thousand dollars
your fourth year okay if you've made
three sales that each paid you $10,000
you know how to do it the fourth time
you didn't you're lucky but if you made
a sale only one time and you got
$100,000 you've never done it again
you probably got lucky if you've done
anything one time it's luck if you do
three times it's great so I produce that
generates confidence for an individual
to be thinking about saying you've done
this three times guess what I'm not an
amateur I know how to do the four time
and then the other part is that I look
at all my data and whatever data I have
I try to beat whatever data I have
currently today so if I did something in
our biggest month ever was 300 policies
we sold in a month my goal is to do 400
policies in a month I don't say oh that
guy's doing
3,000 I'm at 300 my god I can't beat
this guy so I'm discouraged you know I'm
not trying to beat that guy right now
I'm trying to be 300 to go to 400 to go
to 500 to go to 6-under we started off
selling 50 policies a month today
you know last one we saw six thousand
six hundred and fifty four policies in a
month because we went from fifty to
hundred hundred to two hundred two
hundred to four hundred and we brought
it up so you know rule of threes and
contributing your prior best I remember
I don't know how long ago was maybe it
was two or three years ago
again I don't know the number I do
remember you did shut down the channel
value tainment for three months and the
plan was to maybe not even come back and
it kind of Concerned some people
obviously got a lot of comments about
people being upset with the fact that
the channel was shutting down is this
are you going to create content forever
or are we again going to get a time or a
moment where you decide to suddenly shut
down the channel I don't know how long
how much longer I'll be creating content
but value team is gonna be around for
quite some time but me creating new
content I don't know how long that's
gonna be wrong you know it's crazy to
say this but when we first started you
know I had no idea
what direction we're gonna go obviously
there's some things I like that you say
and some things I don't like that you
say but this is gonna sound weird I see
a lot of me and you and I just relate
you I don't know what it is I feel like
we have a lot in common but having said
that I know you've written many books I
know you got a book coming out can you
tell us a little give us a sneak peek of
this new book that you have coming out
with Simon & Schuster this is a book
I've been looking forward to coming out
for while women working on it for a good
three or four years and it's a book I
wish I would have when I was coming up
even if it's 18 years old or 21 even
though it's tailored for c-suite
executives and entrepreneurs it's about
you know in your next five moves no
matter what aspect of your life and no
matter what phase of your life you're at
if you look at a chess player right a
grandmaster somebody that typically
you'll say they'll say he or she knows
they're next ten or fifteen moves right
so as they're playing you they already
know what they're gonna be doing to you
based on whatever you'll be doing right
in life it's the same thing I'm going to
be making this move now that's gonna
lead to this one then this one then that
one right because many times you'll see
people that are trying to do move number
28 on move number three and that's why
they don't get to move 28 because
they're trying to do too early and when
you do it too early you're not creating
the necessary sequence to get to 28 and
also on top of that with this book your
next five your next five moves is
something that as you go through it
you're gonna learn there's a whole
section in the book about how to put the
right team together and there's a whole
section in the book about powerpoints
that the world of business and life is a
lot of power plays if you don't know the
right power plays others will be playing
the power plays on you so there's that
section that people will read which I
can't wait to get to folks to go through
but yeah again a book I wrote that I
wish I would have had years ago when I
was first getting started in business
look I can make one commitment for you
here's a commitment to make to you in
front of everybody this is come a moment
you I guarantee you no one's gonna
promote your book more than I will
that's a commitment I'm making to you
right now on camera it's on camera I'm
telling you right now I'm committing to
moving a lot of your books and by the
way obviously we're getting to the end
of the interview if you have any
thoughts and if you have any comments
that we're gonna put his Twitter handle
where you can send them a tweet and or
you can send me a tweet as well
what you took away from this interview
but for final thoughts and we'll put the
link of the book below as well if you
want to go find out more about the book
final thoughts you talk about this book
being your next 5 moves I think it's
fair to finish on this note is what are
your next 5 moves it's a good question
my next five moves are
[Music]